ofsted's Chief Inspector says that
stopping School inspections in England
would not be in the best interests of
children the head of the school's
Watchdog was speaking after calls for
the checks to be paused following the
death of a head teacher in January Ruth
Perry took her own life while waiting
for an inspection report which
downgraded her school from outstanding
to inadequate well joining me now is Sir
Michael wilshaw he is former Chief
Inspector of schools in England and head
of ofsted from 2012 to
2016. now good afternoon to you sir
Michael and can you understand why there
are calls to scrap these kinds of
inspection reports
yes I can and it's a real tragedy uh
but
this teacher took her like an absolute
tragedy my
my heartfelt condolences go out to her
family
ever since offset was created in 1992
there have been calls for its
abandonment towards abolition at various
at various stages all I would say is
that um offset being I think has been a
Force for good for our education system
and I say that not just because I was a
previous Chief Inspector of schools and
and head of ofsted but also because I
was a head teacher and a head teacher
for nearly 30 years and ofsted was very
supportive of what I was trying to do to
improve standards in the schools that I
I led and we have to remember
how bad things were before ofsted came
into being in the early 90s standards
were incredibly low even in London which
is the standout area in the country
standards were very low offset has
helped to raise the standards
immeasurably to the point where the
latest Pisa results the those are the
international league tables show that
England is one of the best performing
countries in the oecd
um and there are lots of reasons for
that but but ofsted is one of the
reasons but so Michael is there a better
way of refining the performance metric
so it doesn't just boil down to that one
descriptor
or remember that one overall
effectiveness descriptor encompasses
everything that the inspectors have seen
on that two or three day visit so it
looked so inspectors will be making
judgments on the quality of teaching and
learning the quality of leadership the
quality of assessment the results of the
children the progress levels of the
children etc etc could go on so it's an
encapsulation of all that to provide a
balanced view to parents
of whether the school is good or not you
must remember that this is not about
just telling the school whether it's
good or or not but parents parents have
to make a choice about schools parents
want to know whether the school they
send their children to is good or or not
so but it's a balanced View and in most
cases it is a balanced view forgive me
for interrupting could there be a more
iterative process whereby the head
teacher was given the opportunity to
perhaps address some of the things and
my understanding is that many of these
schools who were originally
outstanding classified were not
reinspected for quite some time so
perhaps things could have slipped over
the years and maybe it just wasn't fair
to them to do it in that way well you
mentioned the word fair I think that's
absolutely critical that it's a bit uh
it's a bit like the police force that we
the police can only police the country
through the consent of the public and
it's the same with inspection School
inspection that we can only do this
effectively through the consent of the
people that we're
inspecting head teachers and teachers
and if they think it's unfair and then
that's a problem and I I entirely take
the point that where one aspect of the
school is deemed to be inadequate and it
overshadows it overshadows everything
else obscures everything else that the
school does well that is a problem and
not Sid has to look at that and I know
that
ofsted will look at the whole idea of a
report card I know the labor party are
considering replacing grades with a
report card
with a list of strengths and weaknesses
in the school and that's something
Austin no doubt will consider the only
problem with that of course is that
parents might be confused by that and
might might ask themselves well
is this a good school or not yes I read
the list it's long and voluminous but is
this a good school for my son or
daughter that's that's the only problem
so if if the grades are replaced and the
overall effectiveness grade is replaced
as is being suggested and the what
replaces it has to give parents a good
idea of the sort of place they want to
send their children
when you were running ofsted did you
see head teachers frequently in in
distress at the prospect of a looming
inspection
um
apprehensive is probably the best word
to use and I was a head teacher and I
had I I was subject to several of state
inspections and I suppose I was
apprehensive but in the main it would be
exceptions to this in the main head
teachers want the great work that they
do on a day-to-day basis to be to be
validated I wanted that I know I worked
incredibly hard and I know my staff
worked incredibly hard for the children
I want that validated and I was prepared
to aggressively argue with inspectors if
I felt they got it wrong and of course
heads and schools have got the right to
appeal to Austin if if we think if they
think they've got it wrong but as I say
in the main offset has been there as a
powerful a powerful agency to improve
schools and I think over the last 30
years they've done that very well
so Michael wilshaw thank you for talking
to us